i'll tell you this is our first show in
the new year
so let me begin by saying it's late i
know but happy new year andy happy new
year
happy new year to you although it does
feel like march
yeah a lot has happened between january
1st
and whatever this is yeah yeah no it the
first
two weeks of this month has felt like a
very long time
yeah um not often that there's a
a crazed insurrection in the capitol
building
and that's just one of the things that's
happened yeah i think dinosaurs came
back to life
and are roaming the earth that's right
uh meteors are having sex in the sky
just every kind of insane thing you can
possibly imagine is happening right now
and um we're all just doing our best to
get through it
now believe it or not it's been two
weeks since twitter
permanently suspended president trump's
account yeah they took his account away
they shut him down
i know and it's been two weeks and
this is true twitter says that since
banning
president trump misinformation about
election fraud
is down 73 percent
on its network i thought there'd be some
difference but
73 it's just a crazy coincidence
you're not related there's there's no
there's no correlation
whatsoever 73
and that's made me wonder how have our
lives
changed since trump has been
banned from twitter well i thought we'd
take a quick look
outside and see has the world changed
since our president
has been banned from twitter let's just
look outside and see what's going on
[Music]
so
[Music]
i like it it's nice once again
it's a coincidence that stuff
uh no it probably is because he stopped
tweeting yeah
well i for one am happy that icebergs
are defying gravity and reforming
[Laughter]
that's if they kept that part in it's
all editing